السلام عليكم خيو
كيفكم
شفتوا خالتي شي ولا لا
صعبه
وهو يقضي معظمه وقته بالاتصال بمن يمكن
بحثا عن عشرات المفقودين من اصدقائه
وعائلته من بينهم خالته من محله في منطقه
كريت باك واسط برلين يعني بنت عمي وحده
منهم
وخالتي هلا راحوا يدوروا عليها واصحابي
يعني كتير هلا اغلبيه اصحابنا
على هاتفه صوره بلدته المدمره وابني خالته
الذي يبحث عن والدته بين الركام
بتقول امي يعني هلا قبل شوي حكيت مع عمي
يعني كل يوم
ميتين لهون عم ندفنون هيك يعني البلده
يقول احمد تركت بمفردها منذ يوم زلزال ولم
يكن قد وصل اليها لا مسعفون ولا مساعدات
لحد هلا ما حدا كان
يعني كيف يعني شو بيطلع بيدهن الشعب هو
كان عم يسوي هيك يريد احمد ان يسافر الى
تركيا ليساعد عائلته ولكنه غير واثق
النمته وكيف يمكنه الوصول وسط الضمائر
المحيطي ببلدته